did you ever imagine that you become
this like Tick-Tock star you know what
I'm saying I mean well you know my
daughter Vivi said mom come on do a
dance I'm like I'm not gonna do a dance
on Tick Tock yeah she's like just stand
up and I was in my sweats
[Music]
and so I did a little Tick Tock with her
and and then so it began and then I had
to learn and I really do enjoy it and I
hope that the government does not take
it down I'm just saying I enjoy my Tick
Tock we enjoy your time
alone gotta tell you man I'm a little
geeked out I'm sure you've lost a lot
but you know your talk show made a huge
impact on this little queer kid so oh
that means so much to me you don't even
know
every time it happens it warms my heart
talk to me about this podcast on words
with Rosie O'Donnell what can we expect
because I think some people will see
your name attached to a podcast and
think oh that makes sense she had that
talk show for you years but it's
different right yeah it's completely
different you know a lot of people had
asked me to do podcasts before and I
don't really listen to podcasts really
but when I started doing this I started
listening so it was like a very I'm
gonna have a steep learning curve
because I you know unlike Broadway shows
or TV talk shows I watch that a lot
before I have to do it you know you know
when you do a talk show or stand-up
comedy it's a presentational art form
you present something that you've worked
on and you've practiced it and honed it
and and I'm trying to have more of a
conversational presentation than a
performative one sure so you know I I
was thinking after we recorded a couple
of the interviews last week I said I
should have called this chatting with my
friends because you know what do you do
you call your friends and you say could
you help me out I'm trying to figure out
how to do this would you come by to my
house and you know I was very lucky I
have wonderful friends and I've met some
great people and I I get to talk to
artists that Fascinate and inspire me
and and to real people going through
struggles that I I meet in my life and
on Tick Tock sometimes do you think
you'll ever have your kids on the
podcast and have conversations with them
yes when you know Dakota I'm living here
with my youngest and um so the 10 year
old said she would have conversations
with me oh my gosh she knows a lot of
facts she has autism she's very verbal
and she enjoys doing the little Tick
Tock video so I said will you come and
sit down with me in front of the
microphone and we can just talk and she
said all right then she's so curious and
so unique and quirky and I am just so
thrilled to be on this journey with her
yeah how about the rest of your kids
Blakey and Teresa got engaged right I
mean 23. and in between them we have
Chelsea who has three babies and she
lives in Wisconsin what's it like to be
a grandmother to all these babies it's
hard to believe and it's hard to not you
know steal them and just take them home
with me and girl you know they're mine
now you know what about a key moment in
the game my uniform bursts open and uh
oops my bosoms come flying out that that
might draw a crowd right I think they
were men in this country awaken your
bosoms A League of Their Own your first
movie I mean it's celebrating its 30th
Anniversary I can't believe it I can't
believe it either and I love it because
you know obviously in the film
um sexuality wasn't a theme at all but
then in this reboot series it was
something that really was like the focus
what was it like for you to take part in
and I don't know re bringing this
franchise back out but also addressing
those kind of story lines there was
there was a lot that wasn't talked about
and the time we did that movie you know
gay people weren't starring in Will and
Grace you know people weren't out of the
closet yet it was a different world in
the early 90s and you know Penny's
decision to not tackle that as well was
you know was her own to make and she did
and and I think that uh you know she
made a historically gorgeous film and
and I was so happy to participate in in
the new Incarnation which I hear they
just got picked up for four episodes but
they should have been picked up for a
whole other season now
epic television The League round series
was epic and so beautifully written and
beautifully shot I absolutely love it
and that representation I think was so
important too because you know those
queer story lines weren't just made for
film and TV it was the real life as well
yes and it is and it remains real life
and we all have to stand together all
sensible kind-hearted people and stand
up to this anti-trans mania this anti uh
drag queen
anti-drag queen breakfast it's an insane
insane reaction and we have to question
all those who would perpetrate that
going back and back by all of these
grounds all of this ground we have
covered you know and now in our lifetime
as gay people just for me to think you
could be out and in Show Business I
never thought that when I was a little
kid no nobody talked about who was gay
no one you know so the world has changed
and I'm very happy that I'm here for the
ride speaking of queer icons you're pal
Madonna you know she's been fighting the
good fight for a long time she's also
going on tour
um are you are gonna try and catch her
while she's in town oh I'm gonna catch
her many times I think I'm gonna go
opening night I've had so many times
that I've been lucky to see her perform
she's a a meteoric talent she's a once a
generation Talent she's an Elvis she's a
Michael Jackson She's you know Madonna
and I think she's carried herself
gracefully through all of the different
factions and and and uh
all the different
presentations that she so artistically
has put together for the last 50 years
you know so uh people should never
underestimate her okay so League of
Their Own was remade right yes yeah out
of sleeveless in Seattle now and then
The Flintstones and Harriet the Spy
which of those projects of yours would
you like to see be remade well you know
what would be a great story I just
thought of it now Michelle Trachtenberg
taken care of her old mother who's kind
of losing her Marbles and it's golly and
it's uh and it's Harriet wouldn't that
be something I do that in a minute I
mean I need you guys back in a project
together I think that was yeah she's a
wonderful young girl and she's grown up
into a great young woman and I I can't
even believe I've known her since she
was a baby are you able to reflect and
look back on on the amazing things
you've done throughout your career are
you all about moving forward onwards if
you will yeah onward not necessarily
like throw things out but just like here
I am now and if I got 30 Summers left
I'm a lucky woman let's make every
single one of them count let's get
together with the people that we love
you know I'm I'm one who enjoys getting
older because my mom died at 39 so I
remember thinking God is it going to be
over when I'm 40 and here I am 61 and it
shocked me every single year that I like
sometimes I look in the mirror or I'm
not even and I catch a glimpse and I go
oh there's an old lady oh it's me like
like the physical changes like you don't
see yourself as as you are you know what
I mean you and it's just it's it's
wonderful I feel like zero to Thirty
you're just figuring out what's going on
30 to 60 you're having kids you get
married you're getting divorced you're
figuring out your life and then 60 on
you have to decide how much quality time
left and what do I want to do with it
now I'm doing a podcast which I often
call a Blog that shows you how old I am
I call people I go hey Ricky do you want
to come on my blog
who has a Blog that's no good yeah but
it's been it's been really a wonderful
thing and I'm hoping that this is the
balance I needed
[Music]